hi I'm Jim carossa I'm a professor at
the University of Massachusetts at
Amherst and I've been challenged to
describe the internet in five levels of
increasing difficulty the internet is
the most technically complex system that
Humanity has ever built the internet is
a network of networks it's a platform on
which all of the internet applications
that you've heard of can be built
hi it's really really nice to meet you
what's your name my name is Skyler
Skyler we're here to talk about the
internet and I bet you must use the
internet a lot right yeah what's your
conception about what the internet is
the internet for me it's just something
to use when I need like to search up
something or right watch videos the
internet is physically these computers
that all talk to each other billions of
computers in the case of the internet
the internet allows us to do a lot of
really really interesting what we call
applications you ever think about how
that video gets to you over the Internet
yeah I have no idea got a favorite movie
Matilda Matilda all right we're going to
actually build an internet I've got
couple of things here that I want to
show you or a couple of toys actually
okay let's pretend that these round
balls are computers and the internet is
something that connects them and right
now the Internet is just one
communication link and Matilda is sent
over the internet
from this computer to your computer so
the internet is a network for carrying
information from one computer to another
now this network here looks pretty
simple doesn't it right it's just one
thing should we add some more friends in
yeah let's say we want to get a video
from here
over to here
how do you think that video would sort
of travel through this network uh maybe
I could go to here to here to here to
here that's right so that's pretty cool
there are actually lots of different
ways to actually go through the internet
to get from what we call a source the
place that's sending the information to
the receiver the place that's actually
Gathering the information together and
that's something we actually call
routing huh but wouldn't it just be
different for it to go from here to here
instead of going from here to here to
here to here yeah so that that's a
really good observation in most pieces
of the internet that's exactly what
would happen we want to take sort of
what's called a shortest path but still
there are multiple paths and why do you
think that might be valuable maybe one
way is like messed up or broken so you
don't know why
exactly so Skyler that was a great
discussion about what we just built and
I wanted to talk to you about or ask you
about maybe one other really important
part about networks and it's not so much
the thing itself the physical thing but
more about the rules about communication
that's governed by something that are
called Protocols are you up for one yeah
knock knock who's there lettuce lettuce
who let us go on
a knock knock joke is an example of a
protocol right the computer that you're
using say makes a request you ask for
something you get something in return in
the internet there are protocols
everywhere so that two computers that
have never talked to each other before
know the rules for talking to each other
this Global Internet with billions of
people using it are just lots of smaller
networks that are all hooked together to
each other but also what the internet
allows are all of these what we call
applications Zoom video playing Services
can all run on top of the same internet
yeah so there's one internet fall mom
exactly there's one internet and lots
and lots and lots of things that you can
do on top of it
foreign
well we're going to be talking about
computers here today we're going to be
talking about the internet I always like
to think of the Internet by analogy to
say Road systems for example where you
have you know roads in your neighborhood
you have state roads you have the
interstate highway system and so the
internet is a lot like that it's an
interconnection of local roads local
networks like the network in your house
for example how does like all of the um
networks in my house connect to all the
city networks that's good wow great
question often it's a little blue wire
called an Ethernet cable so that cable
is able to bring bits of information up
into your apartment at say a billion
bits per second that's pretty fast right
literally a wire that goes between a box
in your apartment sometimes called a
router or a modem in your apartment that
comes from an internet service provider
come into this first Network and then
that now Network connects to another
Network connects to another Network
connects to another Network you can face
some FaceTime somebody who's like in
Australia you can talk to them at the
same time and like you're reaching the
same signal so how is it that it gets
there so fast we could talk about that
by analogy to a road system it's not
just one big super highway it's a lot of
smaller super highways that are all
interconnected and those interchangers
are what are called routers that's where
the Links come together we're talking
about talking to a friend in Australia
so oh it's coming in from the east coast
of the United States to this router and
it's going out say that routers in San
Francisco it's going out on an
underseized cable over to Australia
rather than in this direction up to
Japan so there is a undersized cable the
underseased cables are so cool they're
these big cables that are laid down by
switches they cross both the Atlantic
the Pacific the Indian Ocean so the
underseased cables are how the networks
in Europe the United States Asia are are
all connected together how do you
connect like wirelessly that's really
what we call the first hop it's like
from your phone from your tablet from
the computer that you're on there's no
cables coming in you go over a wireless
connection Wi-Fi is the protocol that
allows your computer to talk to that
first top router over a wireless
communication link and I was wondering
like how there's so many different
movies or TV shows that you can download
and that they're all there and like if
you just play it it just knows what to
play
they're all in one spot ah you said
they're all in one spot in fact they're
in lots of spots in Netflix and so most
applications would like to connect you
with a server that's close to you server
is really just a big computer with a lot
of memory a lot of disks that store all
the Netflix movies and also so that you
don't have to cross over too many
internet links to get from where the
server is to the TV or the device in
your home so when I'm watching Vampire
Diaries in my house how does it know
exactly what to do without getting
scrambled up ah another great question
there's a couple of things that could
happen inside the internet information
is sent in these little packets of
information from the Netflix server to
your your display device and literally
each packet that arrives says this is
the first package for Jenna this is the
second this is the third this is the
fifth this is the fourth and they're
reordered for you as a matter of fact
your computer will say using the TCP
protocol to the server hey I didn't get
packet four can you resend it again and
again the Netflix server is very happy
to send you packet four again the other
is the Internet Protocol if you think
about sending letters through the US
Postal Service how you've got an address
on it so every packet that flows from
the Netflix server to you has an address
on it says this is going to Jenna it's
going to the What's called the Internet
Protocol address of your device think of
all the the range of devices that are
hooked up to the Internet it's totally
amazing right every single one of them
has one thing in common and that is they
speak the IP protocol the Internet
Protocol that was a great question
so tell me a little bit about yourself I
am a senior at New York University I
study computer science have you taken
any courses on the Internet or studied
it at all I've taken applied internet
technology so we've talked about
back-end slash front-end Frameworks and
libraries things like that okay
um so really at the application Level at
the application Level for sure I want to
ask you a little bit about what you know
about the history of the internet have
you heard of arpanet for example I have
not heard of arpanet okay back into the
1960s there was a research agency in the
United States called DARPA the defense
Advanced research projects agency
actually was called arpa at the time
they wanted to build this notion of a
packet switching network not a circuit
switch Network like a phone network
where you get a dedicated path and a
dedicated set of bandwidth and links
from source to destination so what would
package switching enable I'm sure
there's something big here for sure
there's there's a lot big right and so
remember this was a Department of
Defense was they wanted to have forms of
communication that were very robust that
were survivable right packets could all
find their own ways be routed
differently through the network so if
parts of the network failed you could
Route Around failures sounds like uh the
reason for like a request response type
of yeah uh structure so you can sort of
see how the network architecture that
wasn't
designed to be 100 reliable inside the
core of the network and had that
complexity built into the edges of the
network and to me the really cool thing
is you you put this infrastructure in
place and then all these Super Creative
people think about amazing things to
build on top of it and you see this
proliferation of amazing applications
abstraction I think it's the reason why
everything spoken like a real computer
scientist right you're a computer
scientist I'm a computer scientist we
talk about apis application programming
interfaces right the API for the
internet is something called a socket
right and a socket simply says I can
communicate if I know your internet
address you know
128.119.40.186 right that number is the
IP address of my server the University
of Massachusetts if you know that you
can write a program anywhere in the
world and send a message and it'll pop
out at my end right I will be remembered
during that I've heard that there are
like seven keys to the internet
something like that okay well I don't
know about the number seven but there's
something in the internet that's sort of
similar to that it's called the domain
name system the dns's role is to
translate names like
gaia.cs.ums.edu or ibm.com or
facebook.com to an IP address so that
your application can actually send a
message to that name to that named
service this whatever quantity of people
is is able to have some form of control
so that's a great question who do you
think controls the internet I'm pretty
sure the internet is fairly
decentralized okay what does that mean
no one Authority holds control over any
sort of decisions or destinations so
that's that's 98 true right and if you
own a network work like your att.com or
your verizon.com you can do within that
Network you can do what you want right
so in that sense the internet is very
decentralized that the control of the
network is up to whoever owns the
network the two percent where you said
there's nobody in control there's a
little bit of centralized control
there's an organization called the
internet Corporation for assigned names
and numbers its responsibility is to
handle as the name I can suggests names
and numbers it's that little bit of
centralization central Authority that
you need when can we see the next
tenfold increase in in Wi-Fi speed you
know in terms of tenfold speeds of
increases depending on what device
you're using right now it's available
all you need to do is upgrade right so
there's the Wi-Fi protocol is called
802.11 and this is sometimes a source of
confusion for people how can it be that
I've got a connection at 100 megabits
per second from our our TV into our
router 100 megabits per second not
enough package dropping where do they
get dropped do you think
somewhere in their travel process
exactly right and maybe they're dropped
in your apartment but much more likely
they're dropped because of congestion
somewhere between the Hulu or the
Netflix or the Disney server if you're
watching a video and you're home so even
though you've got
200 megabits per second on that last hop
you don't have 200 megabits per second
from the server into your into your
apartment I see I'm curious as our
conversation sort of changed your view
or sort of taught you new things about
the internet I think that I've sort of
realized that it's a the internet is a
technology that's dependent upon so many
other factors some more in our control
some less
tell us a little bit about yourself I'm
Casper lant I'm a PhD student at
Columbia University under Henning
Schultz tutelage oh good pronunciation
thank you I'm interested in networking
iot and sort of what kind of data
science you can use with the data sets
that you get from such devices one of
the things that I designed before
starting my PhD with heading was a iot
pill dispenser essentially which which
pairs with your smartphone which does
facial detection and other computer
vision controls and can basically tell
who's taking some sensitive medication
and make sure that they've taken it
correctly we have these low power
devices they're sort of at the edge is
it just connecting them in across a
wireless device across a wireless link
is that the primary challenge or well I
think the primary challenge is that for
sure but then an additional challenge is
keeping everything configured in the way
that you expect it to be configured so
for example most iot devices require you
when you're configuring them to for you
to enter some kind of captive login
portal where you connect to a local
network that the iot device produces and
then you can input your Wi-Fi SSID and
password but then say if you were to
change the password or the name of your
Wi-Fi network or you move to a new place
then suddenly everything needs to be
reconfigured right because that's a
problem that scales linearly right that
you don't want the complexity of
managing them to go up linearly with
that you'd like it to still print stay
pretty flat as you start adding right
exactly I mean the good thing about iot
devices is that they tend to transmit
very very small amounts of data we're
used to ethernet cables that can handle
many hundreds of gigabits per second
over a wired device what are the typical
data rates iot devices I mean not
hundreds of gigabits no I mean I would
imagine upper bound kb per second lower
bound you could see bytes per second
just on average but I mean say that you
have a temperature sensor running off of
your Arduino that's reporting that
temperature in your house every minute
that's going to be far less than
kilowatts per second on average my cinch
is you're you're spot on but they'll
produce over time a lot of data and that
a lot of iot is about Computing on that
data that computation happened mostly at
the edge or somehow a combination
between the edge and something happening
in a far away data center well my sense
is right now that all that data tends to
be centralized because iot devices are
usually the commercial products of
companies do you think they'll share it
not without some persuasion but I I
agree that these data have massive
massive research value something I'm
interested in with my research is
collaborating with people who manage
these distributed sensor devices and
then taking advantage of those data sets
and comparing them to say say you were
interested in doing a research project
on how daily rush hour traffic impacts
the acoustic landscape of New York City
figuring out look this Street next to
this school is causing decibel ratings
above what we mandate and so there needs
to be an intervention here I think for a
long time the internet hasn't grappled
with but now has with iot and also with
cellular networks generally is the
question of Mobility do you imagine in
the future that it might be possible for
mobile devices not to always have to
connect through the same provider to go
from one network to another definitely I
mean we're already seeing long-range
networks like Laura that can first of
all provide access over a much larger
coverage area but then also look the
same because they're set up to the same
specification regardless of where the
individual Gateway is
so hey Jen it's great to see you again
good to see you Jim we're in level five
now so you're the expert expert I'm a
huge fan of the work that you did in RCP
the routing control platform being a
precursor to software-defined networking
and the notion that rather than having
protocols actually always compute things
that we could compute things
in data centers I'd be interested if you
could sort of just reflect back on that
time and sort of the beginnings of sdn
and where it's come since then yeah and
when we were at ATT the thing we found
was frustrating is at T would buy
routers and they would come pre-baked
with a set of protocols a set of knobs
that you could turn if you wanted to
influence how the traffic flowed and a
set of dials you could read to
understand what was going on inside the
network right you couldn't directly do
what you wanted to do exactly and so we
started thinking about earlier work that
was done in the telephony network the
old telephone Network and there they had
the same problem and they had the idea
of having a computer running a program
tell a distributed set of telephony
switches what to do but the idea was
like wow it was kind of a revelation
like what would that look like if we did
that not for the whole internet but at
least att's part of the internet so in
other words use software instead of
distributive protocols to tell the
network what to do yeah do you see the
softwareization of the internet as a
whole happening so so far it hasn't very
much I mean basically software-defined
networking exists let's say within a
single provider backbone or single Cloud
providers Network or a single campus
there's been some work on doing it at
the juncture points between a pair of
networks but one other Trend that's
happening that makes it more possible is
it used to be that to get from one end
to the internet to the other do you have
access networks getting much closer to
say Google or Microsoft or other large
Cloud providers where even you might
only go through two networks right so
some people have called that the
flattening of the internet right so I
think it used to be on average you would
go through 10 different networks to get
from a source to a destination exactly
and if you take that even further
there's starting to be more Edge
Computing where you might imagine you
might have a cell tower connected to a
small number of routers connected
directly to a server that's going to be
running the application in that case the
entire infrastructure might be
controlled by a single party it's
totally fascinating to me that we have
such an important Global infrastructure
and yet the laws that that govern it
tend to be very very local there are
tens of thousands of separately
administered networks and of course in
hundreds of countries and the fact that
it even holds together at all is kind of
a miracle right well it holds together
because we have standards and we have
protocols exactly protocol standards for
how the equipment talks to one another
and increasingly certificate authorities
that help bootstrap the secure encrypted
and communication between end hosts so
there are a few of these sort of
centrally kind of agreed upon kinds of
infrastructure but for the most part
each network runs itself and certainly
we've heard about some countries that
impose firewalls that don't let certain
kinds of traffic out or certain kinds of
traffic uh in so there's no Global body
that is regulating that not really
because each country really can have its
own laws its own norms and so they can
decide like the great firewall of China
can decide they don't want to let
certain content be accessed by the
citizens inside that country so if a
country decides they don't want to
answer requests for a particular domain
name they say hey I don't want to let
someone know the IP address of this
website they can decide not to let those
answers be delivered inside their
country and so encryption plays a role
in in helping people you know keep their
privacy or prevent surveillance but it's
not perfect right it's often possible
still to to know a fair amount of what
people about what people are doing even
if you can't look inside the envelope at
the letter that's right right I mean
even you could just tell that two people
are communicating even though the
traffic itself is encrypted so you don't
know what they're saying just even
knowing two devices are communicating
exactly and in fact if you look at say
the sizes of the transfers that they're
doing you may know hey I'm talking to
Netflix and by the way this is the the
length of the movie I watched and right
this is the second confirm or guess a
lot of things exactly you're one of the
most awesome networking researchers that
I know I'm curious just to pick your
brain what do you think are some of the
Hot Topics in networking research where
do you think the field is heading yeah
I'm excited about the convergence of
Wireless Communications you know
cellular networks Wi-Fi with networking
and cloud computing and in particular
we're seeing in in Edge Computing a
convergence of all three or you might
have a mobile phone or a drone or some
other kind of device connecting over the
wireless medium directly to a network
that connects you directly to the server
that might run your application so you
want the computation close to where the
where the end point is exactly and I
think that what what's now exciting
about that is all three of these
Technologies Wireless networking and
Cloud which are normally three different
communities three different sets of
Technologies through different sets of
Standards or practices now have to work
together in close close harmony to be
able to serve as applications that are
really critical and that might be
interacting with the physical world in
ways where safety is is a potential
concern you know we've had cellular
networks now for for 20 30 years so when
we hear about 5G what's trumpeted the
most is the fact that oh super high
bandwidth right but I sense that the
exciting things are more than just the
network being faster I agree it's both
the high bandwidth it's the low DeLay So
that you can have these applications
that interact with the physical world
and need answers in real time it's about
having the compute really close so that
you can integrate computation and
communication it's about having more
coverage coming back again to the
softwareization sdn and softwareization
is a maybe a little bit behind the
covers that you wouldn't normally see it
as a user going from 3G to 4G to 5G you
just see an increase in speed but yet
the way the network is now being managed
again I think is bringing the cellular
networking World sort of into the
internet World in terms of the
softwareization completely agree
management and I think the bringing in
of compute and storage is important too
I think when you think just about
networking it really is often just one
part of the it they know the information
technology ecosystem as there's often
compute and storage as well and so I
think now there's an opportunity to have
all of those parts of the infrastructure
work together towards an even higher
level goal and so I think it's a really
exciting time to to be in the field
because now the plumbing is getting
close to the application in a way that
it wasn't wasn't before
[Music]
so I really hope you've enjoyed this
video and I hope you've also understood
the internet is part of the worldwide
Global Communication fabric it's
absolutely fascinating how it works